we never thought this day would actually
come but lucifer a fan favorite series
that had escaped certain death twice has
signed off for good with season six the
creative dramedy about lucifer
morningstar abandoning hell for los
angeles premiered in 2016 on fox it ran
for three seasons before it was
cancelled netflix quickly stepped in to
save the show for season four although
the super sized fifth season was
supposed to be the show's swan song the
streamer surprised everyone by renewing
lucifer for a sixth season which debuted
in september with 10 episodes among its
highlights the final season explores
lucifer's life as a parent and brings
back some familiar faces like officer
diggs from the series pilot but there
was one important character who didn't
get as much screen time as they had in
previous seasons chloe's daughter trixie
my name's beatrice but everybody calls
me trixie
that's a hooker's name
what's the hooker ask your mother
well trixie was never a major player on
lucifer she was central to both chloe
and lucifer's lives trixie enjoyed a
close relationship with lucifer over the
years but in season six she was
relegated to attending science camp the
series instead focused on the arrival of
lucifer and chloe's daughter rory rory
traveled back in time from the future to
meet the father she never knew as such
trixie appeared sporadically and her
time on screen mostly focused on
mourning the death of her father so
where was trixie for the majority of the
season when netflix renewed lucifer for
what was believed at the time to be as
last season scarlett estevez began
booking new roles and ostensibly
planning for life after the show estevez
joined the fourth season of the disney
channel series bunked in 2019 which may
have been a cause for concern amongst
the fans looking forward to the
character's return i'm parker i've heard
so much about you and quite frankly i'm
a little frightened
oh thank you in february 2021 co-show
runners joe henderson and ildi mojovic
assured fans that they would still see
trixie in the second half of season five
and season six they explained in both
season 5b and season six fans will still
definitely get their trixie fix we adore
scarlet and shuffled things around a bit
to make sure we could keep the tale of
the future president of mars going the
shuffling occurred because estevez had
also booked a christmas movie for disney
titled christmas again filming occurred
at the end of 2020 which overlapped with
production on season 6 of lucifer but
that wasn't the 13 year old actress's
only other work commitment she had also
landed a lead role in an upcoming disney
channel original series it seems that
estevez's smaller presence in the final
season was the unfortunate result of
scheduling conflicts that's a shame
considering how much fun it sounds like
estevez had on a set of lucifer scarlett
estevez is still a young talent but she
is already a pro at doing interviews
in the past she has spoken about her
experiences filming lucifer and based on
what she'd had to say it sounds like she
had a blast to working with her co-stars
while speaking with daily dead estevez
was asked about tom ellis and leslie and
brandt her response was glowing
tom is awesome he has daughters so he is
really good with kids lucifer doesn't
really enjoy being around trixie but i
would say in real life he's happy when
i'm around and leslie ann is the best we
have a really great relationship offset
we've gotten together on days we aren't
filming a couple times and i really love
being around her and it's not just her
fellow cast members who estevez loved
working with on twitter the series
showrunner ld modrovich posted a
behind-the-scenes picture of herself and
estevez with the caption scarlett's
estevez is truly an angel in this earth
estevez responded with her own tweet
writing quote love this sending you a
big hug it looks like even though her
screen time in the final season ended up
being limited estevez enjoyed her stint
on the show luckily fans looking to
revisit the character on lucifer can now
stream all six seasons on netflix check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]